dans les voitures électriques comme dans
les téléphones cellulaires et quantité
d'autres produits ce qu'on appelle des
terres rares
alors qu'on tente de s'affranchir du
pétrole voilà qu'une nouvelle dépendance
s'annonce les métaux rares qui ne sont
pas aussi écologique que certains
peuvent le croire
le journaliste guillaume pitron est
l'auteur de ce livre la guerre des
métaux rares il est avec nous ce soir
pour parler de ce livre bonsoir bonsoir
ça tombe bien là avec toutes les
informations sur les voitures
électriques mais d'abord quels sont les
métaux rares
comment quelle définition on peut donner
aux métaux rares est bien dans la nature
vous avez ce qu'on appelle les métaux
abondant le fer le cuivre l'aluminium le
zinc eux ce sont des métaux des grands
métaux abondant et puis vous avez
également dans une mine des métaux qui
sont présents dans des proportions 1000
2000 3000 fois moindre que les méthodes
abondant et scellé mais ce sont les
métaux rares donc ils sont pas si rares
on en trouve partout sur terre en
surtout essentiel
ils sont donc un peu beaucoup plus rare
que les métaux abondant et puis surtout
ils sont essentiels ils ont des
propriétés chimiques qui sont telles qu
on en raffole on peut pas s'en passer
pour les technologies vertes et les
technologies numériques d'aujourd'hui
alors quand on parle de technologie
verte la voiture électrique justement il
ya beaucoup de métaux rares dans une
voiture électrique on va voir un dessin
de cette voiture là avec les différents
métaux qui sont justement dans ce type
de véhicule alors typiquement dans ce
dessin on voit des métaux rares et plus
précisément des terres rares qui sont
une famille de métaux rares est ce que
l'on voit c'est que pour les différents
composants de la voiture a commencé par
la batterie qui occupe tout le fond du
véhicule dans la batterie peut peser
jusqu'à la moitié du véhicule il faut
certains métaux rares comme et bien le
lithium ou le cobalt mais également
quelquefois dans des batteries certaines
terres rares comme le cérium hélas
lantagne et puis dans le moteur du
véhicule électrique également son moteur
il faut un aimant qui remplace le piston
est 7ème en effet de terres rares
notamment une terreur qu'on appelle le
néodyme donc moins de pétrole dans la
voiture électrique mais plus de métaux
rares plus de métaux rares plus de
terres rares et donc vous dites que
l'extraction et le raffinage des terres
rares sont très polluants
vous écrivez que pour faire du propre
finalement il faut faire du cheval
expliquez-nous en fait moi je suis allé
me
d'extraction de terres rares et plus
généralement dans les mines d'extraction
de métaux et de minerais rares et
également des usines de raffinage est ce
que l'on voit là bas notamment en chine
où l'on extrait on raffine ces métaux
c'est très polluants excessivement
paulhan et les impacts sanitaires
environnementaux trappe puissant et ça
ça vient contredire l'idée qu'on se fait
des technologies dites propres verte et
pour faire des technologies propres et
bien dans le phase de procès selon le
faux processus minier et ses salles et
donc c'est un paradoxe que le verre
n'est jamais complètement versé une
pollution qu'on ne voit pas l est pas
chez nous elle est ailleurs et donc on
croit qu'on les verts on n'est pas
vraiment vers lire on la calcule pas on
ne l'intègre pas d'un le coût
environnemental ou le coût écologique de
ce qu'on produit en fait on le calcule
et on fait ce qu'on appelle des analyses
de cycle de vie acv c'est à dire que la
de la mine jusqu'à la décharge on est
capable de dire une voiture électrique
voilà ce que ça pollue mais tout le
monde part dont le dire sont fichés un
petit peu des acv ce qui nous intéresse
c'est de savoir si vous polluez quand
vous roulez en voiture électrique pour
ça qu'elle est zéro émission est propre
et verte
parce qu'à l'instant où vous roulez elle
n'émet pas de pollution puisqu'il n'y a
pas de pétrole qui sort du pot
d'échappement sous forme de gaz donc on
ne fait pas ce calcul lahontan
consommateurs mais certains
scientifiques font ce calcul et les
calculs seront disponibles sur internet
sont très faciles à lire
et quand on voit ces calculs plus
généraux plus globaux avec la pollution
un peu partout dans le monde on fabrique
les composants de la voiture
là on la voit cette pollution on peut la
calculer est-ce que c'est soutenable
est-ce que l'extraction et la production
de ces terres rares 2025 2030 2040 est
ce que c'est soutenable personne ne sait
moi mon ma conviction c'est que ce n'est
pas soutenable c'est à dire qu'il va
falloir tellement de terreur tellement
métaux rares pour toutes les
technologies de stockage de
l'électricité donc les batteries des
voitures électriques pour les voitures
électriques elle même je vous rappelle
qu'on attend on s'attend à ce qu'il en
est des centaines de millions qui roule
dans le monde entier demain et chaque
batterie passe plusieurs centaines de
kilos à chaque fois et puis pour les
éoliennes et puis pour les panneaux
solaires tout cela en réalité ça annonce
des chiffres de production qui sont
colossaux avec démultiplication de la
production ces métaux rares d'ici 20 à
30 ans multiplié par dix vingt trente
quarante cinquante deux sens pour le
lithium
donc si vous demandez si c'est
soutenable je répercute le message de
beaucoup de d'industriels et de
scientifiques du secteur qui disent non
ce n'est pas soutenable alors comment on
atteint
comment on arrive à atteindre nos
objectifs et à réussir notre transition
écologie qui avec l'objectif de
remplacer les énergies fossiles
c'est bien de remplacer l'énergie et les
énergies fossiles il faut les remplacer
parce qu'elles émettent du co2 et si
l'enjeu c'est d'éviter de réchauffement
climatique qui plus est au canada où le
climat serait chiffrée chauffe plus lent
plus rapidement je veux dire que dans le
reste du monde
alors oui il faut la faire cette
transition simplement la pollution qui
n'est pas émises par les rejets de gaz à
effet de serre elle va être émises
autrement notamment au niveau de la mine
et donc à choisir je préfère encore une
pollution minière qu'une pollution de
l'atmosphère
moi je pense qu'il faut la faire cette
transition on peut peut-être six
arrivées mais à condition qu'on corrige
les effets pervers de cette transition
c'est à dire toute cette pollution qu'on
ne voit pas et pour cela il va falloir
comprennent des solutions radicales des
décisions radicales en ce qui concerne
l'origine du minerai la traçabilité le
sourcing un peu plus éthique et ainsi de
suite
parce que là présentement tout est
fabriqué produits en chine en très
grande partie les terres rares qui vous
êtes allez justement dans ce qu'on
appelle la silicon valley en des terres
rares une région de la chine
c'est vraiment la chaîne qui est
championne des métaux rares
en fait est rare tout à fait les tera et
des métaux rares en général c'est à dire
que nous avons la capacité en occident
et d'ailleurs nous avons pendant un
temps produits nous mêmes ces métaux
rares il reste du monde mais médoc et
d'ailleurs on pourrait tout à fait
extrait avec tara au québec mais on a
fermé les mines de métaux rares il ya 20
30 ans de cela parce qu'on voulait 30-40
ans parce qu'on ne voulait pas de la
pollution et donc automatiquement ce qui
sait faire mais chez nous c'est ouvert
ailleurs en chine notamment mais dans
d'autres pays du monde comme la rd congo
où on a commencé à extraire du cobalt du
graphite du magnésium qui n'est pas
vraiment rares mais importants pour les
voitures et également des terres rares
et c est donc en fait cette pollution
nous l'avons déportés nous l'avons
délocaliser et donc ce sont d'autres
pays qui assument le coût écologique de
cette transition énergétique
et c'est ainsi que la chine se retrouve
avec toute la production de ces terres
rares et de ces métaux rares dont deux
où nous ne voulons pas mais du coup elle
se retrouve avec un gigantesque pactole
elle se retrouve assis sur 80 90 % de la
commercialisation et l'exploitation de
métaux qui sont stratégiques pour la
transition énergétique donc il est trop
tard pour nous il est trop tard pour
l'administration trump aussi qui
voudraient exploiter davantage métaux
rares il
jamais trop tard et on peut pas être
responsable et désespérés comme dit
l'écrivain français saint-exupéry donc
il y a des solutions
et la solution d'un point de vue
économique géopolitique serait de dire
je ne peux pas continuer à dépendre de
la chine pour 80 % des
approvisionnements en métaux rares ou
terres rares je vais ouvrir des mines
chez moi ou à les diversifier mon
portfolio de sourcing de façon à ne plus
dépendre de la chine et de la sorte et
c'est ce qu'ils essayent notamment de
faire trup tron devrait ouvrir des mines
de métaux critiques aux états unis
et puis re développer le recyclage etc
pour en fait avoir ce qu'on appelle de
la souveraineté minérales dont il n'est
pas trop tard
ça prendra du temps c'est très long le
temps ministère le temps d'ouvrir la
mine
et puis tout l'aval de la mine le
raffinage c'est très long mais rien est
impossible alors guillaume pitron
malheureusement faut s'arrêter ici mais
c'est très intéressant et c'est
passionnant à lire la guerre des métaux
rares merci merci à vous merci beaucoup